George so it's been nearly a year
incredibly since we did that now
Infamous interview in New York a lot has
happened to you in that time I was
struck by a tweet as he flew into Los
Angeles to do this interview he said
just landed at LAX and as I'm deplaning
I had a gentleman come up to me and
thank me for my service in
Congress now because it's George Santos
I have to ask you first did that happen
yes it did yes it did do you think you
deserve to have that kind of response
from the public you know I invite all of
folks in the media here to come back
home with me and ask the people
yourselves don't don't believe me you
don't need to believe me right I've been
discredited for an entire year in the
media it doesn't matter how much I've
admitted to what I I where my
shortcomings were and where I did commit
I was less than truthful right but well
last time you admitted you're a terrible
li My point so the reality is is I I
invite folks to come into to my hometown
and take a look for yourself I am not in
the same predicament that the media has
propelled for the last year this is a
very common response I've received
there's a sense of outrage back home uh
after the expulsion really yeah there
was pretty I'm conservative peers people
voted for a conservative person for that
District after 26 years of Democrats and
I went in there and I was conservative
through and through the most
conservative member from the New York
delegation nobody voted for the George
Santos yes they did you actually are
that's not true they voted for the fake
version you that's not true they they
vote they voted for the principles the
agenda the political positions that I
performed and and that I did you not
think any of the lies matter no nobody
voted for me based on my resume and I've
seen that actually trend on Twitter for
quite some time people saying I didn't
vote for his resume I voted for his
policies and guess what he delivered on
each and every one of them I never broke
a single campaign promise a single one
pierce do you know how many politicians
can say that very few what did you
actually achieve though uh you know what
it's it's it's very hard to achieve
anything when nobody is give me your
main achievement as a congress my votes
I I I maintain but what did you actually
achieve well like I said I was this
guy's thanking you for your service in
Congress what did you actually achieve
thanking for me I I that's a question
for him right he was sitting
next what do you think you achieved I I
think I achieved standing standing my
conservative ground I never buckled I
never I never bend it over to the
establishment or to the liberal mob in
Congress I've always kept my it was the
liberal mob that got rid of you no it
was liberal mob yes it was it was a l of
Republican sure but not a majority of
them a minority of Republicans along
with every single Democrat almost I you
were the first Republican Congress
person ever to be thrown out yes that's
true ever that's true there only ever
been six Congress people I'm the six
right there's only three were in the
Civil War yeah right who were confessed
two were indicted and two crial
convictions yeah I didn't have any of
that and then well not yet well unless
you can tell the future well no you're
facing 23 federal charges and I'm I'm
fighting them I'm fighting them
seriously but they're serious they're
serious yeah so I mean since I saw you
last in less than a year everything that
you were then has gone up in smoke you
accept that oh a lot has gone up in
smoke but I'm still here right it's
irrelevant people still want to talk to
me they still want to hear what I have
to say do they oh they do you would be
having this interview if they did well I
think you're a fascinating person but
mainly because of what's happened to you
in the last
year confirming people's belief that in
many ways you were one of the worst
people to ever be in Congress and you do
you understand why people think that I
disagree I didn't sell out my country I
didn't take a single vote that would put
a man or a woman in the Frontline of a
war I didn't vote for anything that
would further a globalist agenda
I love my voting record and I stand by
it I actually think I have one of the
very few voting records that somebody
can actually put their head in in bed
and sleep at night without worrying
about how far down the river they sold
the American people pierce you know when
you look at some of those records over
there people who voted to put us into
endless Wars nonsensical Wars because of
political vendettas that a president had
of his daddy's UNC uncon UNC nonc
concluded efforts in the Middle East or
whichever way
it is that they they they rationale to
put people at War I never had to take
that vote and I would have not voted to
put us at War quite frankly I I've I
drew a line into the sand that I said
enough Bloodshed of Americans enough
American treasure being literally blown
to Smithers abroad I I I I I support my
voting record and I think it's one much
better even though it's only 11 months
of a voting record it's better than
people who have been there 30 years
right but then in November M 2023 a
house ethics report found that you had
blatantly stolen from your campaign
that's not true and exploited every
aspect of your house candidacy for your
own personal financial profit true
that's also not true well that's what
they found well that's what they think
that's what they speculated they didn't
come to a that was a conclusion no that
was not a conclusion that ethics report
was not a conclusion it wasn't again it
was on the basis of that that the vote
happened that threw you out Pierce just
look at this their report is so so
lambas Al bad Michael guess is such an
AB failure of a chairman of the Ethics
Committee he has his own issues with
ethics himself I don't think he knew
ethics if it looked at him in the face
but would you it it I do and in his
report think ethics mean well give me a
second let me conclude this thought in
his report he says that I'm exonerated
from any accusation of sexual harassment
towards a potential staffer which was a
blatant false hit on me by somebody who
just wanted to infiltrate my staff and
then on his expulsion resolution he said
says that I committed uh sexual assault
against that same individual which one
is it Pierce it's a contradiction that
nobody can understand it's so sloly done
that wasn't why you were thrown out well
the fact that it was contrarian to what
was in the report but was in the
resolution to expel me should just give
you a little glimpse of understanding
how sloppy the process was there was a
there was only one accepted
predetermined result and they didn't
want to do the full investigative report
which would have taken why would your
own fellow Republicans be party to
throwing you out if you're such an
innocent little flower I'm not saying
I'm an innocent little flower nobody's
an innocent little flower neither you
are neither I am none of those 434
members in Congress right now are I'm
saying we're all human we all make
mistakes we all are flawed human beings
and I believe that fundamentally but the
way that this Witch Hunt of an Ethics
investigation on me was in Congress was
completely unethical it says a lot when
I have to say in sight that the do J has
been far better courteous and respectful
of the process that we're undergoing and
the Ethics Committee just completely
squander them the irony of what you're
saying is that it they found of an
extensive investigation that it was you
that had been completely unethical uh
for example you spent campaign money on
Botox treatments luxury fashion
purchases trips to Atlantic City and Las
Vegas holidays in the Hamptons even your
own rent that's not true none of is true
no it's not as a political candidate we
travel all across the country to raise
funds Las Vegas Atlantic City Hampton am
I the first politician with an
expenditure in the Hamptons with
fundraisers attached to it they're full
of crap it's baloney they just they they
just use buzzwords to get folks like you
in the media to be able to go up in arms
and say oh my God George Santos did this
and that and ABCD I don't care about
what you did well my point is I didn't
do any of that and they know D so when
they say you were frequently in debt
hadn't abysmal credit School relied on
an Ever growing wallet of highin credit
cards to fund your luxury spending
habits is that also un true I I'm not
abysmally in death wasn't then am not
now have always paid all my credit cards
off and the amount and volume of credit
cards I keep that's just to show you
that they're out of touch with the
American people every single American is
dwindling with highin credit cards
because of decisions politicians like
that make in Washington DC I was no
different was no different but is that
shameful to have in I don't have abysmal
credit like it's it's it's baloney it's
absolute from the Ethics
Committee because there are a bunch of
little Lords who have if you look at the
panel of the committee just look at the
committee for the whole itself right and
you look at the records of all those
people those people have all been in
politics their entire careers they don't
know what it's to be a regular C you
claim to own multiple properties in a
luxury car a Maserati is that true I'm
sorry you claim to own multiple I own a
Jaguar I don't own a Maserati do you
ever claim to own a Maserati I I have
not I own a Jaguar I own the Mercedes in
the past a Range Rover but not a what
did you tell your staff campaign stuff
you had a Maserati uh I'd love to see
that that was in the report and I didn't
even read that part in the report is
that not true I have a Jaguar I have I
love my Jaguar you never told one of
your staff you had a Maserati no not
that I recall of I always drove a
Mercedes during the campaign and then a
Jaguar you used
to pay credit card debt and make
purchases from companies including
Hermes only fans and Sephora okay and
you did this from a company Redstone
which paid you at least $200,000 and you
use that money to then go on the
spending spree with those things is that
true okay no I'm I'm not going to go
into the details of this because it's
because it's it's such yeah but
hang on George you can't say that some
of it is and then when I ask
you a specific like that say I'm not
going to talk about that I'm going to go
this way I'm not going to continue to
unpack what I already did on the house
floor of the United States I call this
out on the house floor on debate of this
expulsion it's it's so misconstrued it's
so twisted and spun that report Pierce
that report no cop in America would
bring it to a DA no decent da no decent
prosecutor would look at this report and
say this is a legal finding report that
is a political spin assassination you
called the committee the committee is f
look not even all of the members of the
committee voted to expel me you call
them unethical you said that it's all
I called Michael guest
unethical but specifically this company
Redstone that paid you at least
$200,000 did you use that money to pay
off credit card debt I've said no
purchased things from hermes's only F
I've already said no you didn't I
already said no yes you didn't spend any
of that money on those things here's a
here's a deal pierce the way that they
did this it was designed to hurt me
because they needed a way to get me out
I'm not here to hurt you no I'm not
saying you I'm that's and I'm telling
you the truth and I'm defending myself
I'm not going to stop none of the
findings they found the truth Pierce I
provided them with all the documents all
the financials and then they released my
taxes all out in the public which is
something that I didn't even give
consent to like I lost all my rights as
an American citizen my my my Hippa
rights were violated my my privacy
rights were violated every single right
of mine was violated by the Ethics
Committee and nobody's talking about
that nobody nobody cares to talk about
the fact that my hipop rights are
violated my my privacy rights are
violated the Ethics Committee did a
number on me if I were like any other
regular politician matter of fact if I
was Michael guest I'd be sitting in a
corner crying in Weeping but I'm not
Michael guest I have a backbone and I'm
not going to stand I'm not going to cow
to to to to what they want to if you're
so innocent why are you facing 23
Federal CH I'm going to go ahead and
fight that I'm not discussing my doj
proceedings on TV this is not where I'm
you were the first to mention the doj I
gave a contrast but I'm not discussing
the process right but what you get my
point if you're as innocent as you're
trying to make out why would you be
facing 24 23 federal charges which could
carry a punishment of 20 years in prison
I guess you'll see that once the process
plays out that's all I can say but
you've denied all these charges like I
said I'm playing the process out not
getting into the do proba you have
denied them as a matter of fact yeah I
pled not guilty but you're aware of the
severity of the charges no I'm very
aware you know conspiracy to commit
offenses against America wire fraud
false statements falsification of
records and documents aggravated
identity theft access device fraud
unlawful monetary transactions of a
$10,000 theft of public money these are
serious charges they're serious charges
and I'm playing the process and fighting
them as I
go but if you've denied them all none of
them are true like I said Pierce I will
not be the discussing an ounce of the
doj you've got to have considered this
is going to come up in September I think
your yep September your case right Tri
if you're convicted you will likely go
to prison for a long time are you
prepared for that pierce like I said uh
it's a scary it's a scary thing to be
facing it's a it's a long barrel to be
looking down and of course uh uh like
any other human being I would be worried
scared and concerned but right now I'm
going through the process and I have
faith
I have faith but in your Quiet Moments
away from the public George Santos when
you think about what may
happen that's that's a tough thing isn't
it it's not easy no it's it's definitely
not easy but we we go along with the
ride and you just got to take it on the
chin and take it like a champ and move
on life goes
on since we did our last interview
obviously I went through a lot of things
which people had said you were lying
about and you I've dispelled a lot of
them in the media afterwards and I was
able to get Vindicated on at least some
of them I'm going to go through them
just to just to bring us up to speed to
see where we are with all this right so
on schooling you said you attended the
prestigious Horus man School in New York
for six months the school said there was
no record has that record emerged were
you there I'm sorry no you were never
there no why did you say you were well
the the at Horman there was an
enrollment there was you weren't there I
was not there for various reasons but
you claimed you were that's fine yeah
and and I I I admited afterwards that I
was yeah I'm just curious why well it's
a long story Pierce uh is there a short
version no there isn't really isn't it
just that you lied no no it's not just
that I lied there's there's a longer
version of it it's try
me Pierce it's it's a long TR me George
it's a long story I've got all day well
so do I does your camera does absolutely
look we'll get more film it has to do it
has to do with my parents getting
getting me a deal to enroll and then the
whole thing falling through and then
just not being able to afford it so it
was an enrollment and yeah but the lie
was that you said you went there yes yes
yes I didn't go there business education
I've already cleared that up with you
and with everyone else right so business
education we established in our
interview last time that you're claiming
to have got a degree in economics and
finance from burck college and a masters
from New York University were both false
that hasn't changed right there's been
no that was false again has that changed
you just made it up like we said last
time any any other reason that you want
to share or was just you made it up no
okay you've claimed on your resume that
you worked in Wall Street you then said
it wasn't written by you is what you
told me last time it was not but by a
staff F you said to me you have plenty
of emails to prove you were
uncomfortable with that have you produce
those emails yes and what do they
establish it just establishes that I'm
not comfortable with the way the bio was
written and the way the CV was written
that's that somebody was inventing a
Wall Street career oh no no not
inventing a Wall Street career I worked
in in finance and capital markets for
years let's establish that between
linkbridge investors met Global and um
uh Harbor City even though Harbor City
ended up being defunct after my
departure the reality is I did have the
career I did have the
relationships people like to say that I
never worked a day in my life that's a
line that runs ramp did you work in MRE
well in in in the sense of Wall Street
on Wall Street proper no in that
industry around surrounding Wall Street
yes your Jewish An ancestry you always
claimed Jewish and Ukrainian ancestry
and said your grandparents survived the
Holocaust and fled persecution when I
quizzed you about that in my last
interview you said you would battle this
to your grave and I will you said you'd
ordered four DNA kits and were're
waiting on their return to confirm your
ancestry I have them have you used them
they're going to be be using a
documentary so they're embargoed right
so it's been I nearly a year since you
said you were going to do that well I
decided to do it in my own terms and
they're they're it's getting done and
you believe that DNA test will prove
that you are I know it will I know it
will I know it will and I'm looking very
much forward to it a disabled military
veteran said you set up a GoFundMe
account for his beloved dog Sapphire who
had a tumor in her rib cage but then
didn't give him access to the funds
unless he used a vet recommended by you
of a dog then died we talked about this
last time you said you'd never met this
veteran or offered to help his
dog that's true is that still your
position that is still my position even
though he's adamant and was after seeing
the he he said it on Anderson pooper
that he's never met me but he knew it
was
me so so none of that story is true look
I've seen the story I've read everything
I've seen the GoFundMe screenshots
it it was not me directly for sure I I
don't recall the dog and I have helped
many animals many people came forward
after his story saying well I had a very
different experience with George so you
know that nobody reports on those your
mystery marriage certificate you said
you'd show me once the cameras stopped
rolling but you didn't can you show me
now is there a marriage I I probably
have it but I'm not going to show it to
youa you can't show me not on camera
I'll show it to you after it rolls just
remind me y yep how long have you been
married Mar since November 20 uh
November 2021 who you married to Matt is
his name who's Matt Matt Santos that's
his last name Matt Santos yep I love
that you guys are so intrigued with my
spouse well only because you'd be
married to women marri I was married to
a woman now you're married to a man it's
interesting but is that is that very
unique at all uh no okay that's not
unique it's at all you've just been
quite frankly you've just been very slow
in being forthcoming about it uh no I'm
not I've always said I was married to
woman first I mean folks folks who know
me knew I was married the problem is the
media thought they knew me and they just
wanted to create outrage quite recently
when I when my husband and I wrote a
condolence message to uh late Senator
Diane Feinstein here from California the
the media went nut saying that I hard
launched the husband although I had we
had talked about my husband on your show
nearly a year ago that's the obsession
the the short mindness is trying to make
everything about me news nobody talks
about that Obsession about the media no
ician you love being news no politician
has ever gone under I've never met
anyone other than Donald Trump who loves
being in the news good bad and ugly
reasons than you I ever I don't like
being in the news but I've learned one
thing here I've learned one thing after
Congress you don't like being in the
news I did not like it at first now I've
learned one thing now you love it well
of course it pays my bills the more
don't like actually you love it back
then I did not like it it was very
off-putting I when you run for office
you're running for office but I don't
think you quite comprehend everything
else that comes with it and all that
lack of I guess privacy you lose your
privacy rights essentially right so we
talked about your mother who I know you
were very close to um you doubled down
in our interview that she had died as a
consequence of 911 but there's still no
record of her ever working anywhere near
the Trade Center um no one's been able
to find it in fact quite the opposite
they found evidence of visa application
showing she wasn't even in the country
at the time do you want to green card
holder visa application that doesn't and
she died 15 years later and there's no
evidence she died of anything relating
to what happened on 911 well so here's
your chance to clarify that's already
been clarified in the documentary coming
out later this year well you can't keep
saying you put stuff in a documentary
but it is there and I can't talk about
it I have a contract on it but is your
position that your mother still died as
you see it in the documentary and you
the question I can't answer it that's
ridiculous I can't it's embargoed in the
doc your new position is I've got a
documentary I can't no not on everything
I've been giving you answers there's
things that are embargo to the
documentary and I'm I'd love for you to
see it do do you accept that if you'd
invented that that would be pretty awful
anybody who would invent something like
that would be awesome so if you if you
constructed a story that your mother
died didn't constru 911 Pierce let's put
it this way I would never construct
anything about my mother my mother was
my best friend my mother was my favorite
human being and the fact that I have to
see people write and the vital around
things the disgusting things that people
have called my mother and the disgusting
things that people have said regarding
mother I mean the disgusting garbage on
social media the most heartless people
live on social media behind a screen and
the fact that I have to see look I don't
want be fair to Trolls but what I would
say about the criticism is that you
initially implied to people your mother
died in 911 and was in the towers she
was nowhere near the towers she didn't
work in the towers she may not have even
been in the country your documentary May
well reveal the story about that but
certainly there's no evidence that your
mother had anything to do with what
happened on 911 you'll see you'll see it
in the documentary I promise
you promise you that the Pulse Nightclub
we talked about that again we did talk
about that um that you said you lost
four employees in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting can I can I clarify something
there when I say for employees not my
employees I didn't own the company and
the employees and and I I doubl on they
weren't hired they were in process we
the company had just moved to Orlando
was in a massive hiring spree and this
was the information given to me at the
time by the people up top in the company
and I maintained that position I have no
reason to infiltrate myself into a
disaster like that nilly Willy and the
great thing is the record show I was in
Orlando on that night I was in Orlando
that entire year matter of fact of 2016
um and it's it's just so frustrating
that people try to say he said he owned
the company I never said I owned the
company when I work for a company for
instance you work what whatever station
you work for whether it's Fox Nation or
Sky News you wear their shirt at least I
do and I say the company my company the
criticism is George that people think
that you've attached yourself to a lot
of very big moments in history whether
it's your grandparents and the Holocaust
whether it's your mother a 911 whether
it's a Pulse Nightclub mass shooting
that you have used these events to
promote yourself in some way as being
attached to these things to make
yourself look better that's how does
that make you look better because
they're saying that you were somehow
involved in some way that you're you
were the grandchild of Holocaust
Survivors you were the son of a of son
of a 911 Survivor and so on that when in
fact there's no evidence these things
are true hundreds of thousands of people
are associated to Holocaust
descendants how does that make anybody
look better well it was a tragedy yeah
but it's it's a story that that adds to
your compelling personal narrative
unless it's untrue here's the most
frustrating thing that happened to me
last year was me losing my voice that is
something I could never uh explain to
you how frustrating it is what do you
mean losing your
voice my my my story was told by
everyone in the media all the Talking
Heads I never got you didn't lose your
voice oh I you sure you didn't stop
yapping all year oh no that's not true
it is true that's not true I could Yap
all I want I can talk all I want but at
the end end of the day everyone in the
media had the final say I never got the
final say to anything nobody ever nobody
bothered to to do any real digging you
in our interview doubled down on your
denial you'd ever performed as a drag
queen despite pictures per as a drag
queen that one picture that one incident
in a carnival when I was 18 years old so
you did perform as a drag queen I did
not perform I dressed up once I was 18
years old come on Rudy Giuliani got
motorboated by Donald Trump and nobody
called him a career Dr que an
assassination attempt you said happened
on you you said that there been that is
translation well the Rachel mad show got
the footage of the podcast where he made
this claim translated it word for word
you denied you'd ever said that You' had
an attempt on your life an assassination
attempt in fact the exact translation of
what you said on that podcast in Brazil
was we have already suffered an attempt
on my life an assassination attempt so
you did say that I did and I've suffered
many more after words last year
assassination attempts there's there is
a man in right now in trial or in the
process of whatever it is the doj is
doing in Florida for literally
conspiring and telling us leaving a
voicemail at my congressional office he
was going to kill me and my husband and
it was a serious you know why was
serious a man had a rap sheet he had
time he served or whatever the case was
he left the explicit voicemail
and Capitol Police acted on it and the
doj and the FBI and you know we we we
all my staff provided their their
affidavits I provided an affidavit uh uh
uh House Council took over it and and
they represented it so to to to think
that to diminish as a public figure how
many public figures go through all sorts
of attempts every year we've SE we've
had several scary I've had death threats
I'm just curious while you said on a
Brazilian podcast something which you
then denied saying it it's not it was
poorly translated and I stay convicted
to that it was a threat not an attempt
and they translated it as an attempt the
way I worded it I've listened to it
several times the way I conveyed it to
many people who speak Portuguese with me
said yes you're saying you had a death
threat and they decided to go ahead and
translate it into an assassination
attempt so you look it's it's going to
get into murky Waters of translation and
we all seen how that can go down e
either way it depends on interpretation
of who's translating it obviously Rachel
madow people are going to interpret it
in the worst possible light so there
were some things we didn't get around to
I wanted to clear up one was that you
were a Volleyball Champion you told a
radio show in 2020 you were a star
volleyball player at baroo College well
we can all know where that ended up
right was that true no I played
volleyball in high school definitely not
in college right you at Baro college no
if you weren't there let alone being a
star volleyball player all of it was
invented yep why George oh here's there
so I gotta tell you if I you said you
slayed Yale Bar's volleyball team well
they did they actually did slay Yale but
I wasn't part of it farook's volleyball
team didn't even play against Yale in
the period you claimed to have been
there they did they did so you were
claiming to be a volleyball star for a
college you never went to in a game
where you slay Yale even that they
didn't play Yale in that period every
single part of it was a Whopper pretty
much yeah unfortunately again
why here's the thing I don't really get
about you because you're very
charismatic you have a lot of qualities
I can see that I just don't get the
constant lying for no reason what's it
about you must have thought about this
yourself is now cost you your your
political career certainly for now right
what's I like that you say certainly for
now well you me listen Donald Trump's
back running for the White House nobody
thought that would happen I'd never say
never for you you're young right the key
question is have you learned from what's
happened to you absolutely look but can
you expl can you explain to people why
you have been such an habitual liar
often for no
reason Pierce it's it's deeply rooted in
the process of politics back in New York
I've said this so many
times
oh if only I could some things and
sometimes I I look I'm not at the
liberty of speaking of on certain things
because again I have an entire process
with the doj ahead of me so it'd be
stupid it'd be ill advisable and uh I
wouldn't do myself any favors but
there's some people think you have a
sort of mental disorder I don't have you
ever have you ever had any
treatment first of all I am not a
pathological liar second of all what you
think that means well somebody who's
lied for a living yeah you have but
that's not true so you're saying that
out of my 35 years of existence the the
stupidity of the last two years is going
to make up for the entire of my entirety
of my life I would say that the Litany
of lies you told when you decided to run
for office absolutely constitute
pathological lying and and the question
again I can you do me a favor though can
you look up at some other politicians
who lie probably worse oh sure I mean we
all saw dick Blumenthal listen I'm going
to come wait let me just stop you there
I'm going to come to the potential
hypocrisy of your situation all right so
I will come to that I'm just curious you
must have had time to self-reflect
you've been out now of Congress for in a
couple of months when you self-reflect
have you been able to work out what it
is about you which made you lie so
brazenly so often but often for no real
reason that anyone can really work out
other than you just lied you know Pierce
no
there's there's nothing I can say to
that there must be a
reason no really no for unfortunately
now but you you're sure it's not a
mental disorder it's not a mental
disorder how can how can you be certain
okay well are you willing to diagnose me
here and now no I'm just curious how do
you know how do you know it's not oh
Pierce life hasn't been pretty I'll put
it that way um and clearly um
the last two years were tough um things
that happened in the campaign I could I
could barely ever even attempt to start
explaining it so I I always choose to
just it is what it is it really
is it's it's just but what it is is
pathological lying yet you don't want me
to think you're a pathological L you say
that you can say that well you don't you
don't think that's fair you don't think
it's fair no but it's your opinion is it
fair no no it's not but it's your
opinion I don't but explain why that's
not accurate doesn't matter what I think
Piers no it doesn't because you already
have your predetermined thought no I
don't I'm only interested in facts by
your own admission both in the last
interview and again today you have told
repeated lies about almost every part of
your life and the question people are
wondering now you flamed out is why
because you actually came into Congress
as a breath of fresh air you had a big
win you were seen as an electoral
big electoral force a Powerhouse the
Republicans was a Powerhouse and you hit
Congress you you were the first openly
gay Republican congress with a 16 and a
half Point Victory Swing for a Biden
seat so all of this was great right you
and yet you've blown that whole thing up
because it turned out that you just had
told Endless Lies and the question is
everyone wants to know and you've never
really answered is why and it's
fascinating to me that you just don't
have an answer or you don't want to give
me an answer no I I don't have an answer
for
you I really
don't something in your childhood
no nothing no nothing triggered this
no no
nothing you can't explain it no can't
explain it
can't explain it sorry piar it's you
don't to apologize to me oh I I think
you probably you probably apologize to
the American people many times and I
continue to do that yeah I don't think I
mean saying sorry to the American people
I'm a terrible liar is fine all right um
but do you Harbor any aspiration to make
a comeback in the political world I
don't know maybe I I'm I'm not done I'm
35 so if you do and I'm not saying you
can't but if you
do you're going to have to explain at
some stage what caused you to do all
this life of course you're going to have
to come up with an answer not come up
with an answer when when I'm ready to
understand the last two years of my life
myself I'll probably be better equipped
to what don't you understand there's
just so much Pierce I I mean I have 23
uh indictments as you mentioned so let's
let's go from there you know it's it's
it's a lot yeah it's a lot it's been a
lot for one human being and I'm still
willing to come here and do these
interviews and I'm still still willing
to talk I don't run away from you guys I
don't run away from your tough questions
I think that's fair you you know but
guess who does the majority of the
cowards in Congress who sell the
American people down the river every
single day a book came out of about you
yeah uh called The Fabulous the lying
hustling grifting stealing and very
American Legend of George Santos by a
guy called Mark chuana Cho right um he
makes a number of allegations about you
but interesting what part for me in
relation to did you read the book no oh
okay so I'm just the interesting thing
to me was one thing he claimed maybe a
theory behind your incessant L he said
you might have a mental disorder called
pudia
fantastica defined by the captain and
sadu synopsis of Psychiatry as a type of
lying in which a person appears to
believe in the reality of his or her
fantasies and acts on them is that
potentially what happened you know let's
talk about fabulous okay now here's a
guy who goes to Simon and schoers and
lies saying he has ample access to me
and he's a specialist on me here's a man
who has been blocked from communicating
with me since December of 2020 lies to a
massive Publishing House gets a payout
off of it and then goes and tries to
write a book now he failed to get a
single family member he failed to get a
single campaign staffer with the
exception of the bribery hire that we
all know uh that that I've it's been
wildly reported uh by one of the
political chairs um and he failed to get
into any single person close to me he
wrote all these fabulous stories that
just didn't happen or some of them are
just flat out made out of cloth or he
just has wild allegations in there with
no corroboration whatsoever other than
he SEC and he calls it a book and he
calls me the fabulous the man's The
Fabulous who grifted and and hustled
Simon and chuster into believing that he
was going to get ample interviews with
me this man sat for over an hour and a
half outside of my father's house with
snow pouring on
him so he's a terrible hustling grifting
liar Terri he's a terrible hustling
grifting liar and you have a problem
with that absolutely why because it's a
books of work shouldn't it the books of
fantasy but on that point about
pudia fantastica I've never heard of it
but this principle that you might have
believed in this fantasy story of your
own life life that you convinced
yourself you had been a Wall Street star
you had gone to Barack College you had
been a volleyball you had been a
volleyball star who beat Yale you had
done all these things that that was the
real you that you genuinely believed it
and then when it unraveled and got
exposed as a tissue of Lies you were
genuinely quite shocked because by then
you kind of convinced yourself that's
what had happened appear I don't I'm not
a qualified professional to make that
claim does that sound plausible no no
that doesn't but you can't offer any
other explanation not now I can't
unfortunately what do you mean I I just
don't have an answer for you have you
ever not had an answer for something
what do you say to your husband but he
he must have asked you about all uh we
we've had conversations did he know
about all the lies or was he no finding
out via the media he found out by the
media and what was his reaction um CU he
loves you he married you obviously not
positive but uh you know we work our we
work our way through our our personal
stuff together he's your husband he must
have asked you to explain
me we have uh had a year for the books
both of us uh with our lives being
turned inside out uh you need to
understand that everything that happened
to me affected my family uh my husband
my sisters my my parents everybody you
know my father my mother's past but um
it's it's it's been tough it believe it
or not it's been really tough to even
sit down and unpack any of it has been
tough I can imagine it's very tough I
don't for a moment think it won have
been and absolutely not up for debate
for the camera is what happens between
my husband and I and my family and I
that that's for me well I'm not after a
debate I'm just curious what their
response was just that's not a it's it's
not going to happen have you have you
cried a lot in the last year I'm an
emotional person I'm not scared of
saying that
um crying is something that I I actually
do a lot in private I don't think
anybody has ever seen me cry but um it's
uh yeah I'm an emotional person very
emotional so it's it's not uncommon I
mean when you look at your trajectory
from the Flying high first openly gay
Republican Congressman star going in at
a ridiculously young age on a wave of
jubilant press coverage and now here you
are little more than a year later and
it's all gone it's not all gone your
reputation has no it's coming back I'm
working on it oh yeah well how's it
coming back I'm working on it I'm
working on it Pierce Everything is
Everything is repairable you're proof of
that many other people in media are
proof of that I believe in comebacks but
I think there also has to be an element
of selfawareness of course and seems to
me the the floor in your comeback as you
put it is that you don't even understand
why you lied to Star Wars that's not
true that's you trying to take my
inability right now told you couldn't
explain it that's you taking my
inability to give you right now an
answer on the spot that would justify
the means come on George you you've had
a long time to think about this no I
haven't no I haven't it's been a year
and I've been sitting down and sitting
back and trying to think about my entire
life for the last year and it's not easy
Pierce it's a lot it's a lot uh so to to
say that to say that I'm not self-aware
is completely an understatement and
grotesque I'm very self-aware of pretty
much everything I don't do anything that
I don't think uh at least 10 times
before these days you still lie no I
have no reason to I think when did you
decide to stop it's not about stopping
or when I decided to start no it's about
lying is stupid period right and and I
think we all know that when you've lied
on your scale when you've been that
dishonest about you every part of your
life not every part you keep saying
every part of my life no not pretty much
you're so you're going to Define my
entire life to my work and education
period that's all that's what you're
doing that's that's literally what
you're doing you're defying my entire
life based on two aspects of a human's
life which one would say is not even 10%
of a person's life right is your entire
life your work and your education it's
not you have family you have friends you
have a plethora of experiences as a
human being so to say my entire life
that's broadly and it's
offensive it's really darn offensive and
I've had to listen to this on and on
again it's like boring at this point
right what what I've done yes it's wrong
and I've I've apologize I've I've showed
Contrition I've showed remorse and I am
sorry but to keep hitting the horse a
dead horse over the head over and over
again there has to be more that you have
to be interested in asking me because I
can assure you there's so much more I
can offer not just you and your viewers
but the world what like what you ask I
don't know you you need to ask you'll
sell yourself if there's there's another
side to you I sold myself I'm a good
person I'm the person that you can call
at three o'clock in the morning if I I
have friends who have t spoken to
journalists I've helped friends out of
abusive relationships I've have I've
helped friends out of literally being
out in the Street I I'm a good person I
go out of my way I take the clothes off
my back quite literally to help people
and some of those people that I've
helped throughout the years are some of
the people who are in that darn book
disparaging me people I help people I
put inside my house that had nowhere to
go Pierce so it's very it the world is
so hypocritical and quick to jump on all
the criticism but none of you guys have
reported ever on a positive thing and
you I will be damned if the positive
I've done in the world don't Trump all
the negative that's out there and most
of that negative is just liable when we
try to find a genuine achievement that
you had done in Congress pretty much the
only thing we could find I'll be honest
with you was in 2023 he co-sponsored a
bill to make the AR-15 the National Gun
of the United States the AR-15 being the
weapon the preferred weapon of choice of
pretty much every Mass shooter in the
last few years in this country well it's
just a fact okay just a fact all right
but that seems to be your only
achievement I mean you proud of that
achievement is that really the only Bill
you can find that I co-sponsored pretty
much the only significant achievement
was that you why is that an achievement
if that bill never got more than seven
co-sponsors and it never went for are
you proud of that pierce I'm sorry I
have to call you out on your is
if your producers and your staff can
only find that bill and call that an
achievement not the plethora of Bill you
earlier to name an achievement you
didn't name one well I co-sponsored over
hundreds of George I asked you to your
face can you give me one achievement
sure I was a co-sponsor of hr2 hr2 is
the Border bill it passed
Congress I mean like I was part I was
co-sponsor of the parents Bill of Rights
hr5 it passed Congress I co-sponsored a
lot of bills that were that passed the
House of Representatives my signature
was on there those are achievements you
still believe the hour5 should be the
National Gun of the United States I
believe that if we have we get to have a
national everything why can't we have a
National Gun and by the way the time the
day you tell me a gun grew legs and go
and went and shot people and not a sick
deranged person who bite quite frankly
now in more in more recent shootings not
that I like shootings not that I want to
justify shootings not that I want to
spin vitriol into rhetoric about
shootings mass shootings are abor okay
let's make that very clear guns were
were designed for self-defense and for
sporting and hunting whatever why would
you make the weapon which has been used
in the majority of mass shootings in
America in the last few years why would
you want to celebrate that as the
natural how different is that from
London barring steak knives because
there's too many stabbings Pierce yeah
we are we are tightening up our knife
crime rules yeah that's crazy so you
can't get a steak knife in London proper
to eat a steak because there's
Psychopathic sick people that instead of
the government in London deciding to
treat them actually more that you got
young kids running around all carrying
knives so the idea is to deter them from
doing that well I I'd say whereas in
America there's no deterrent on young
people there of course there's
deterrence come on oh come on Pierce so
you're saying that we just give out
AR-15s like candy pretty much yeah
that's not true it is true that's not
true it's very very easy to get a gun
easily get a gun in America to get a
Kinder surprise chocolate egg they're
banned because they may be they're choke
hazards they can Chasm kid so
your kid can get shot dead nothing gets
done but if they swallow a little toy
and a Kinder surprise chocolate egg
that's illegal no I know I I I I share
that hypocrisy with you it's it's
ludicrous right yeah it's ludicrous
Kinder Surprise eggs are amazing you've
been on Cameo which is caus a lot of
entertainment to people people to try to
go have you been on there no you should
join you be hit but your rat's gone down
oh it went so the peak it was
$500 and I what are you now 350 I'm
still top 2 how many how many requests
you get a week uh on a good week now now
after the New Year's it's been one week
I've gotten about 35 or 40 something
like that they're still coming in
steadily I reduced them first of all the
reason I I jacked them up was to deter a
little bit of the volume and I still did
1,200 videos in that short spam of you
find that fulfilling when just do it for
money well first of all I think it's fun
I enjoy the the the connection with them
and obviously I have my bills to pay
Pierce and and and if that's how I'm
going to facilitate pay my bills I mean
there's no shame in that it's honest
work
or do you disagree no I think you're
perfectly entitled to do it there's
nothing unethical about doing Cameo I
know lots of people on C like I said I
think you should do it you'd be a hit
I'm sure I would I don't I don't need to
do it well why not is it beneath you I
just think I can't think of anything I'd
rather less do than Day come on you can
do one here there people ask me for
videos I do them for free I I mean I do
them for free to tons do you know how
many people say like oh I can't afford
your what do you want me to say I said
of friends and family do you feel George
do you
feel even if you can't explain why you
lied so much do you feel now that it's
all blown up in your face do you feel a
sense of shame or not really a terrible
shame and i' I've displayed that many
times um but here's the thing I have
nothing to lose the truth will set me
free I am not going to say anything I
mean you know the irony of that
statement well yeah sure there's irony
there but here's theit the truth might
set you free here's the here's right I
mean actually in that one sentence might
well be the thing that sets you free no
here's actually from now on saying I'm
gon to tell the truth well that's what
I've been doing and it's making a lot of
people uncomfortable so I recently was
wearing a pin that said they were fools
to set me free as in my colleagues in
Congress because I just won't stop
talking well some of the things you say
about Congress I think have real
validity right I mean they're true
Congress has passed fewer bills I think
in this stage of the administration
under Joe Biden then in history at this
stage I mean a derer amount of stuff has
actually been passed why what's going on
in Congress why can't it do anything
other than do throw brick bats at each
other it's not going to do anything
because you have members of Congress too
busy worried about their stock
portfolios or about their next gig or
worried about their political
vulnerabilities and what they're going
to do next to make money so is it going
to be coing up to rathon or mobile and
Exon this is what Congress is about
these are the conversations they have in
the chamber they're like I don't know I
think I'm going to lose I don't know
what I'm doing next oh districting is
going to be tough as they're supposed to
be debating and attentively paying
attention to what's voting those are the
sidebar conversations I used to listen
to this is literally what it's about K
Granger during the entire debacle of the
CR last year that led to Kevin
McCarthy's outter and and uh um and
vacating the chair we're sitting in a
room and she is the chairwoman of
Appropriations essentially
single-handedly The chairwoman Who
everything up pardon my crass uh uh
statement here but it was it was because
of her that we were in that predicament
because she didn't do her job as the
Appropriations chair didn't get the
Appropriations bills passed on time she
got up mid meeting about 30 minutes into
it and says oh I don't have time for
this I have to go uh I have to go to a
fundraiser when she damn knew she was
retiring you know why because it is more
important for her to capitalize and
raise as much money as humanly possible
into her campaign account before she
announces retirement when there nobody
is going to give her any more money so
that she has that big cushy campaign
expense so she can fund all her
traveling because it's all political so
she can broke her power through how many
members of Congress do you believe from
your personal knowledge of information
are
liars almost every last one of them no
exception I can tell you no exception
they're all lies very few exceptions who
are the exception I'm not going to get
into who give me one name well I'll give
you one that gets chastized left and
right in the media and he gets destroyed
his credibility but they could they
always fail is Matt Gates they always
try to destroy his credibility and he
always comes out on top right so I'll
put it this way to you in
Congress I'll give you a fair example a
text message I got from from from after
a very long winded conversation I had
with Jamie Rasin on the capital steps a
man who I have respect for his his fight
his determination to serve his country I
fundamentally disagree with him on
almost everything he was eviscerated for
voting to not expel me on the first
expulsion attempt uh but he did it based
on his founding constitutional beliefs
but then he sends me a text message and
says remember George everybody likes The
Comeback Kid remember Bill
Clinton do you believe that I believe
that everybody gets a second chance do
you think what you did was better or
worse than Bill Clinton it was far
nowhere near what Bill Clinton did I
mean
look embellishing lying whatever you
want to call it is wrong
doesn't put a single life at risk
doesn't kill a single person doesn't
destroy anybody it's very different than
what some of these people in Congress do
well you're also accused of 23 federal
crimes that's fine but those are
allegations and those are indictments
those are accusations but if you're
found guilty they are serious offenses
that's fine but again they would have
meant that you abused your position for
personal gain again and again and again
and again so it's not just about casual
lying which has no consequence you if
you're found guilty and you end up going
to prison for long period of time it
will be because you committed a lot of
serious offenses you know that no of
course I know that it's not just a few
casual lies that process is play is
going to play itself out whichever way
it goes and and stay tuned let's see
what happens when you look at Joe Biden
and you look at Donald Trump and they
may be the two that duke it out for the
White House both of them have got a
pretty checkered history when it comes
to
veracity do you think there's an irony
there that you've been thr you've been
thrown out of office for persistent
lying and for these other allegations
but persistent lying is certainly at the
Cornerstone of the problem people have
had with you and yet you have Donald
Trump and you have Joe Biden neither of
whom will probably stand this kind of
scrutiny in fact they haven't done Joe
Biden has been lying since before I was
born Joe Biden was lying in his first
presidential campaign Joe Biden is a
prolific liar Donald Trump I don't I
don't understand what the obsession is
with his lies tell me one lie that
Donald Trump has said that is is even
comes close to Joe Biden just give me
one I saying he had nothing to do with
January 6th right he
didn't he didn't I was there I was at
the ellipse he didn't he was still
speaking I was second or third row at
the ellipse in a muddy pit of cold mud
he was still speaking and there were
people already in their own valtion
breaking into the capital because he
told them to to go down there he said
fight peacefully he'd actually said go
down and fight fight like hell and then
when they did start fighting he did
nothing until he was too late many
politicians have said the terms fight
like hell Republicans and Democrats that
is a fure of speech how many have stood
there having done that and watched
rioting take place and refus to stop it
until it's too late he he acted on it as
soon as he got to the White House come
on he didn't oh come on he didn't the
accusing Donald Trump of having any
involvement with January 6 and turning a
blind ey to Nancy Pelosi being speaker
of the house having declined extra
security measures for the capital that
day at the request of President Trump is
then you're being a hypocrite if you
don't bring up Nancy Pelosi she wanted
the political theater she got the
political theater she wanted a riot she
wanted a riot oh come then don't be
ridiculous saying Donald Trump had
anything to do with it it's equally
ridiculous I find it bizarre that you
don't think Donald Trump has also told
him L of what Al lies in his life I I
just don't I don't see it I mean the
man's wildly successful and quite
frankly everybody adored him until he
decided to run for president everybody
loved Donald Trump I mean you had
everybody cozing up to Donald Trump up
until 2015 it wasn't until he came down
that escalator the man is the first
person to run for office that goes in
and comes out with less money than when
he went in I think he has a lot of
qualities Trump and I understand great
man understand why he's po I've known
him a long time he was good to me I've
said that repeatedly it was good to me
loyal to me when I left TV in America
and went back to UK it was very good to
me and I don't forget that and he has a
lot of good qualities he has some bad
qualities don't we are and I I think the
idea that he is more truthful than Joe
Biden doesn't stand the test of scrutiny
it does it does to you because you're a
republican you you want to say that no
no no because I I've defend I've
defended Democrats I have defended
Barack Obama when Barack Obama was right
I have no quals and I have criticized
Trump as as far as a trump conservative
supporter I am I have criticized Trump
Trump's salt tax deduction was abysmal
for have you heard from him since what
happened no I have not do you expect to
I I he's busy he's running for president
I am he spends his life on the phone I
really hope I am not anywhere near the
top 100 issues of trump right now
because then I would be concerned who
who's bothered to call call you of any I
received calls from my colleagues in
Congress repeatedly I still have great
friends there I I talk to them I was on
before I came here was on the phone with
three of them we're on the phone
regularly I built Everlasting
relationships with people on both sides
of the aisle not just Republicans just
recently I was a Democrat out of Florida
calls me he's had a a mixer or whatever
and there was a couple of my
constituents there giving him a hard
time that he expelled me and he's like
look I have some of your supporters here
and they're mad at me a Democrat so you
know and I don't call names because I
don't want you guys to go make their
lives miserable because that's what it
happens oh why if you're not giving
names it's because it's not true it's
not that it's not true it's because I
know what the media does the moment I
drop a name you're going to go make that
person's life miserable well might just
ask if it's true no no and then you're
gonna why would you call George Santos
don't don't you feel shame I would
you'll spit it well actually I would
respect them more if they did call you
if they were friendly with you before
I've always called people in my world in
my life you I've met if I had a tough
time whatever it is I'll always reach
out to them if times go bad that to me
is what actually being prop human being
does right uh and I got to say there's
plenty of Democrats a lot of people
don't do that yeah have you heard from
from Top
Democrats top Democrats I never had a
relationship with top Democrats but some
of the Democrats have reached out to you
yeah i' look my my sphere of Democrats
who I'm friendly with are like seven or
eight of them just about and yes I've
heard from at least half of them since
I've
left you've revealed recently you were
on a zenic yes the weight loss yeah well
I was Prett diabetic that's why it was
prescribed and then there was the so
when were you first done it uh I started
in Janu so January of 2022 right
beginning of C election year I was 352
pounds wow election day I was
242 pounds and that was all was mic it
was all those mic and campaign and how
long did you stay on it for I stayed on
that whole year and then I went off of
it about March of 2023 my pre-diabetes
uh just after I interviewed you yep just
right after you interviewed me and my
pre-diabetes had been resolved I was my
numbers were just so low it was miracle
drug uh it worked out great and funny
funny you mention o because I'm right
back on it as of yesterday and flying
here to La was a challenge because you
it it it it makes you very nauseous
let's just say that five hours in a
plane didn't help how much weight did
you put on when you stopped taking it
about 40 47 pounds since I last
interviewed with you just just about and
you want to lose that again I want to
lose that and then some so yeah we're
we're is it is it a good thing a zenic
look zenic was designed originally from
from everything I've read to be a weight
loss drug but it got barred because in
this country big Pharma is so enamored
with the fact of let's treat and make
money so you you have your fisers and
your madas they want to treat uh high
blood pressure coronary vascular disease
and and respiratory diseases they don't
want to treat obesity obesity is the
number one killer in America and if if
we were to accept that and make this
wildly available for people to lose
weight I think we would we would have a
healthier country a healthier America
without abuse obviously but I think that
we do need to take a turn into looking
at uh uh obesity and treating it if
Donald Trump was to win the election and
he might well the way the polls are are
going I believe he will by a landslide
if he did and he he decided to bring you
out of the co would you would you accept
what does that mean well if he said to
you I've got some job in my
Administration for you I'd love to work
might look at you and think a young
Dynamic gay Republican all right he's
flaw but so am I or he''s done some bad
stuff so did I but I'm now back as
president I'm going to bring back George
Santos I put it out there I'd love to be
ice director if if was that serious
thing that's serious that's serious what
would you do if you were I speak four
languages I understand Logistics I'm
really good on my feet what would you do
if you the ice it's very simple it's
it's about rest strategizing ice first
of all assuming that the president would
give ice its power back and assuming
that we can go ahead and Sue into
Oblivion all these Sanctuary non
laws so that the federal government can
do its job here's the problem with ice
today ice has been handicapped for
decades at this point nobody has ever
make it taken it serious but I remember
as a little boy 13 years old being on
the seventh train in New York city that
runs into Queens to Manhattan and having
ice stops those were common right after
911 because they were picking up bad
people on the train now why don't we
bring that back I think it's time we act
New York City has probably the largest
propensity of people living there with
removals proceed active removals
proceedings which means you have a
deportation mandate on you and they defy
it and live blatantly in the open there
and we don't have enough ice personnel
there and that's where it should be
quick example as to why when you're in a
sanctuary City you cannot place an ice
hold in somebody that's in detention for
like call it a petty I don't know
shoplifting right but if you're in other
states that don't have Sanctuary status
you can when you have the ability of
putting in icehole that means that
facility will withhold that person for
you until you can come pick them up in
New York they won't they'll just let
them go you need more people there to
wait outside of these jail houses to hey
what's up buddy you got to come with us
so we need to rest strategize and
reshift the Personnel into states and
cities like California New York Illinois
so that we can wait for them as they
come out of the jail houses and just
pick them up that way since they won't
allow a hold I mean it's very easy to do
it's very easy to fix and you need to be
realistic all of these networks saying
there's 12 15 million we're talking
north of 30 40 50 million people in this
country at this point just with the Joe
Biden Administration Alone 10 million
came in in three years there's no way we
have 12 million the situation on the
board ridiculous completely out of
control absolutely nonsense and Joe
Biden has shown no ability my orcas is
even worse my orcas is a dereliction of
Duty if you were to look up in a
dictionary der elction of Duty it should
be Alejandro M oris's face in there now
I mean you talk of der elction of Duty
do you think that you've been in your
duty no I why you're sitting here now
because I served every single day
honorably I didn't do anything
dishonorable while in Congress I voted
honorably I voted I the only votes I
missed was when I had court dates
couldn't control that you've been facing
23 Federal criminal charges I've been
accused of only things before I was
elected nothing after I was elected I
have been accused of nothing during my
time as a member of Congress you told no
lies once you became a congressman I had
no reason to you can look at my record
and reason
before Pierce like I said no but I'm
curious I mean you said I had no reason
to what I'm what I'm try it does beg the
question again reason okay so poor
choice of words not reason there was no
need to lie or no no was need before
George again Pierce I can go back and
sayest with your own thoughts there was
no need but do we all control stupid
sometimes no stupid is stupid you do
stupid things and you can't control it
and you move past yeah I'm just
fascinated what drove it no couldn't
couldn't really put a finger on it right
now you must be able to not now sorry
what that implies you may suddenly work
out what it is it's it's not May or will
it's eventually I guess I'll get my
thoughts together and I'll have a more
uh comprehensive
statement what what should people make
of you I mean when I see you if I if I
divorce for a moment all the lies and
all the charges you're facing and we'll
see whether you're found guilty or not
you've denied it I believe in in due
process and fairness right so we'll see
what happens you do Congress doesn't huh
you do Congress doesn't well they
decided that you behaved unethically and
they had a very hostile report against
you and you became one of only six
people to ever be thrown out of Congress
oh trust me there's more I'll be I'll be
seven or eighth by the end of this year
maybe I mean there are certainly others
who probably deserve it oh no no there
are certainly others that they're now
going to go
people stuff gold bars into various
jackets
right here's my point he said there's no
gold bars here's the point I want I want
to make to you is that I can't help
liking you right there's something very
likable about you as a person I can't
help no a good friend that's what every
friend of mine ever told me well I yeah
so you have a lot of likable qualities
you're charismatic you're good on TV you
know you're clearly smart right you
clearly Got Deep
flaws if you do want to make a comeback
and it sounds to me like you absolutely
do the way you talk about potentially
running ice and such a bad idea right
you lots of energy for it but if you
were to ever even be considered for that
you'd have to tell people and show
people that you changed do you think
you're capable of that I'm doing it all
this year already throughout my actions
and and moving forward you think the the
one thing the American people have
appreciated the most after I left
Congress is me not being afraid to just
call it like it is I saw the sausage
made Pierce and now I just want to share
with everybody how the sausage is made
and why we are in the predicament we are
as a country I mean look you're you're
you're a Brit to you I remember you told
me it doesn't matter what happens or not
for you right this is America you you
you have no skin in the game but I'll
say this to you guys you're a home have
a house yeah I was G to say you're a
homeowner here so here's what I'll say
is Congress is not at work for the
American people Congress has it hasn't
been I think that's completely true it
hasn't been for many decades but now
it's more egregious than
ever they've lost the touch of debt and
a great example is I was smeared and
slandered for having highin credit cards
Min of fact one of those cards an apple
card from Goldman Sachs right oh my God
High 19% APR or whatever the APR is on
that but guess what 80% of America lives
off of those same credit cards and I was
smeared for that that's how out of touch
with reality these people are what would
your mother have said to you about all
this oh she would have smacked me to
hell oh my god oh she was tough lady she
would have physically smack you oh she
would have physically she would have
physically assaulted me why she it was
unacceptable what was everything the
whole thing was unacceptable even what
would she have found most egregious
about your baby I I would just say the
fact that I had to open my mouth and say
anything that wasn't true she would she
would have just beat me her a crisp she
would have P pulled out a wooden stick
you you don't know that one did you ever
lie to her oh I I I knew better than to
do that I knew better oh I definitely
knew better the one time I did I I
caught a beating but it was white little
lie where were you all my friend's house
no you weren't I went there and you
weren't there okay whoops so things
teenagers do nothing crazy does your
father have the same attitude to truth
my father is the most honest man you'll
ever meet so this is again fascinating
to me you've got two parents who sound
like honesty is a real premium to them
honesty hard work stay very big deal for
both wom do you feel like you let them
down
yes yes do you miss your mother I it
sounds like she was hugely important to
you absolutely not a day goes by seven
years December 23rd that I lost my
mom seven years I feel like yesterday
you talk to
I talk you know you're going to call me
crazy but yes every day before I go to
bed I I throw some words up there and I
hope she's always listening what do you
say I just talk about whatever the day
went or how I'm feeling and just like
part of my prayers I believe it or not
I'm actually a praying man still very
much do you think what would have do you
think what's happened to you would have
happened if she'd stayed alive
no it wouldn't because you wouldn't have
she would have guided me much better she
that was my compass right
there sad absolutely it's sad really
sad Pierce life is sometimes uh full of
uh twists and turns ups and downs and um
I'm not immune to it nobody's immune to
it we all go through it and um we all I
believe we all come back stronger from
controversy or from a situation like
this so what will act two of The George
santal Story look like
act two is just truth and transparency
and just putting everything I can and
know out there and just exposing it
people like James comr who didn't take I
had whistleblowers that he didn't take
serious and there's no real interest you
know let's did if you follow the
oversight committee work right into Joe
Biden and Joe Biden's absolute
scandalous uh uh fining es let's say
right they're scandalous I don't care
whichever way you say the whole thing
with Hunter Biden barisma Ukraine all of
it stinks it's it reeks of yeah and
it's corrupt and big Tech's attempt to
suppress the laptop store all of it I
said to Donald Trump to his face if he
just focused on that as the reason why
he lost that election he would actually
be probably on the money when he tries
to claim it was stolen through other
reasons which he hasn't proven Pi I
don't get it Pierce nobody I think
people are scared to try to prove it but
let me ask you this when a state reports
102% of that state voted does that ring
here's the point but does that ring does
that ring rotten to you listen all I
know is every investigation including
those conducted by Republicans has
failed to produce any evidence that that
election was rigged or stolen however
what big Tech did in suppressing the
hunter Biden laptop store
May well have had a material effect on
voters which could have Swan the
election so I agree with Trump about
that so Jack dorsy Mark Zuckerberg byess
the York all I think they all conspired
to try and stop in different ways to
stop Trump from winning then where's the
indictment on Jack dorsy and on Mark
Zucker I think they should be more
accountable I think they should be
indicted for election interference that
was an election that was election
interference it was election
interference it 100% the Miranda Divine
article was on the money yes and by the
way it was a disgraceful suppression of
freedom of the press of course it was in
a country which protects it really
normally and Joe bid said it was Russian
propaganda he lied continuing the big
hoax that Hillary Clinton perpetrated on
the American people that cost us
billions of dollars in investigations
and ludicrous Personnel countless times
of work only to come to a conclusion
there was no colluding with the Russians
so this is what I talk about I agree
with you about that it's crazy it's
crazy look I can talk and I can analyze
politics with you all day long I have
very different takes sometimes in my
colleagues and we could always find room
for disagreement and agree to disagree
but the reality is is like they're all
full of both sides George if you
end up going to prison and obviously
there's a possibility you facing very
serious charges if you do do you think
you could handle it I don't know pi have
you thought about it I I try not to
think of negatives like that I try to
think as positive as humanly possible um
I'm 35 years old I trust the process I I
have not been somebody critical of the
doj unlike some other colleagues of mine
I I always have given organ our
organizations our entities FBI doj CIA
credibility because the moment I lose
faith in them I lose faith in this
entire country so but I I do trust the
process and I'm going to fight it what's
your biggest regret about the whole
thing I have many regrets what's your
biggest if I could do it all over again
I'd do it very differently what would
you do my my story is compelling as is
right as
is you remind me a little bit of um The
Wolf of Wall Street Jordan bord when I
interviewed him he from my district is
he because I said to him you know
everyone told me if he hadn't done the
criminal stuff which was a very small
part of his whole world
he would still have probably been a
billionaire he was that good at what he
did he didn't need to do it and he told
the story very compellingly about how he
got away with this and he got away with
something a bit bigger he got away with
something a bit bigger and eventually it
became a monster that devoured him but
it still remained five% of all his
business he didn't need to do it oh the
Steve Madden thing was just pure
corruption you didn't need to embellish
your story you didn't need to if it's
proven you didn't need to do any of the
campaign funding nonsense either none of
it was necessary you didn't need to do
any of it that if I was you would eat
away at me a bit the fact that it all
was so relatively inconsequential and
kind of pointless if You' just been
honest George Santos the way your
parents wanted you to be and just told
the truth and acted honestly with your
charisma and your televisual appeal he
could have been a superstar of Congress
uh look maybe uh the way I look at it is
God had intended a different path maybe
that that's the only thing I can say I I
believe in and I'm faithful so I believe
in there's always a reason why things
happen a certain way so maybe uh I was
destined to go do other things learn a
little bit about what's in there so I
can come out here and Open the Eyes of
the American people and maybe start a
revolution a political revolution that
we really have to have in this country
and this is not partisan speak there's a
lot of Republicans that don't deserve to
be in the house there's a lot of
Democrats that don't deserve to be in
the house I'm sure that's true I mean
and and I'll say this to you here's
here's one riddle I'll I I'll share with
you are you going to tell me that Mendez
Jr had no idea about his dad's dealing
even though every job he's ever gotten
was thanks to his father and he's a
congressman he voted to expel me isn't
that ironic what hypocritical oh my god
when I saw the roster of the people who
voted for I saw his name I said oh buddy
you you definitely iron is lost on me
when I saw that I couldn't stop laughing
what did your what did your dad say to
you about when you got expelled he said
what's next I said I don't know and he's
like how are you gonna pay your bills
I'm like I don't know do these I
couldn't answer these questions at that
point so then uh a former McCarthy
staffer is like just set up a cameo I'm
like what's a
cameo I knew what the concept was I just
didn't know the app and the name you
know he's like just set this up send me
the idea I go I register I'm like oh God
I hope this doesn't blow up in my face I
register and literally quite literally
within I want to say three hours I had a
100 requests and then the executives got
in touch that the first of all you came
in at a $75 intro I don't know what
you're doing bumped that up so then
that's how it bumped up and eventually
got to 500 I have my own account manager
there who does a great job at managing
the price flow uh peak season in order
not to get get inundated cuz look
there's a limit of how many I can do a
day December was old novelty to me so
sure I had nothing else now I have other
things lined up other projects I'm
working on other uh employment that I'm
I'm I'm negotiating right now that are
going to take up my time so I definitely
can't be available for 1,200 cameos a
month ever again but that's the case and
point is the price points there if you
really want it you'll get it uh I could
never bring it down but that's that's
that's what I told I'm like that this is
the beginning I don't know what's next
but gotta pay my bills gotta do stuff
you know so and working on the
documentary as I told you earlier uh
what's your final message for people
watching this don't count me out you
know
um I've given many people a second
chance and I'm asking everybody to
please give me a second chance and I
will you know come forward and prove to
be worth your second chance and I just
want people to look at that that and and
say so many people uh make mistakes we
all make mistakes if you really take a
look deep inside and I am sorry and I I
look forward to continuing to to be a
voice for for those who seek uh
leadership in me George it's good to see
you again and I wish you all the very
best thank you very much whatever
happens thank
you